FEMALE SPEAKER: Today,
you're clearly all
as excited as me to have Chef
Dominique Crenn at Google.
She is the chef and owner of
Atelier Crenn and Petit Crenn,
both in the city.
Also holds the
prestigious honor of being
the first female chef in the US
to receive two Michelin stars.
Her newest, and I think
first, cookbook, Metamorphosis
of Taste is out today.
You're going to have the
privilege of accessing that,
probably in the back of
the room in a little bit.
So please join me in welcoming
Chef Crenn to Google.
DOMINIQUE CRENN: Thank
you for having me.
Who cooks at home here?
I don't.
That's good.
[LAUGHTER]
What are you guys
cooking at home?
What are you looking for when
you're buying a cookbook?
AUDIENCE: A lot of pictures.
DOMINIQUE CRENN: Great.
Because there's a lot
of pictures on this.
All right.
So the idea of-- I didn't
want to write a cookbook.
I just wanted to write a book,
but you have to make a deal.
So anyway.
This book is not about for
you guys to follow the recipe.
It's for you guys to be inspired
with [INAUDIBLE] and about
my life and about the way that
I'm thinking about things.
My philosophy is about
anything you do in life,
you have to think
before to do something.
So always thinking
before cooking.
And cooking is a way to
for me to express myself.
I'm not just opening
restaurants to open restaurants.
I think it's kind of
boring to do this.
Actually Crenn was a place.
It's a very special place.
In 2009, I had a major accident
where I almost lost my life.
And then I woke up.
Obviously I did wake up
because I'm here today.
But I realized that
life is too short,
and I wanted to
do something that
embraced the way that I'm
looking at life, the way
that I'm looking at people.
So I wanted to create a
place where I could gather
a lot of talents around me.
And to bring a vision and
a philosophy up to life.
It was not an idea
about, I'm a chef.
I'm going to open a restaurant,
because I have a lot of egos.
That was not the idea, which
I think a lot of people do.
But I'm not.
No, it was really a place
to bring people together
to be able for them to have a
platform to express themselves.
And obviously, to have
the same idea that I have.
And to just have fun, and
maybe with that restaurant,
we can start to have a dialogue
with people in the city
and in the world
about everything.
Cooking and food for me
is the core of a society.
Means that everything
that comes from food also
there is economy.
There is social economy.
There is way of thinking,
there is humanity,
there is a lot of things.
So I'm thinking like,
I'm not too cerebral,
but I'm a little bit cerebral.
So this is how we think.
And it's also at Atelier Crenn,
we want to have a lot of fun.
We wake up in the morning.
We work 18 hours a day.
And we drink a lot
of wine at night.
And we just laugh.
And it's not a
regular kitchen where
the chef is yelling a lot.
It's a kitchen where there
is a lot-- I mean here,
I'm sure there's a
lot of talented people
that you guys exchange
ideas every day.
And I think we do the same
thing, and I think it's great.
So I don't know what
we're going to do today.
I've got 35 minutes to go.
That's amazing.
So every dish that we
do at Atelier Crenn,
you're not going to find them
anywhere else in the world.
No dish is an inspiration of
any books or any cook recipe
that you see online.
It's a reflection
of the way that we
think, the way that we feel.
And maybe memories that
happened also through our lives.
I mean, obviously,
I grew up in France.
Some of my cooks grew
up somewhere else.
So I always like to integrate
a little bit of their DNA
into my cooking, which I
think is very important.
Who's been to France before?
I love that.
Did you go to France
and eat hamburger,
or did you go to France
and eat French food?
I don't know.
It's interesting.
So do you guys know that there
is a tradition in France where,
especially at the table, it's
totally different than here
in America.
In America, I mean,
when you start a meal,
I think people start
with salads, right?
I never understood that.
In France, the salad is
at the end of the meal
to kind of bring lightness
and to help you to digest.
So we have a salad.
We finish the meal with
a salad at Atelier Crenn
before starting with
the desert, which
is about seven
desserts after that.
Who's been to Atelier Crenn?
Oh, OK.
When?
I I know I get a lot of Google
people, but when was that?
Did you like it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
was there last year.
DOMINIQUE CRENN: Good.
Anybody complain?
Any complaints?
No?
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
So the way that we
think about things is,
how can we do a salad
without being a boring salad
with just lettuce and vinegar?
So we take ideas.
And so, what is a salad?
A salad is composed with a lot
of different greens and baby
vegetables.
So this is pretty big.
You see, it's like really tiny.
And we have a garden where we
take all the baby vegetables
and salad.
and so what is a salad?
There's a vinaigrette.
I don't know.
It could be ranch vinaigrette,
which is not French,
so we don't do that.
Usually, the regular, the
classical vinaigrette in France
is just Banyuls vinegar with
a little bit of olive oil,
and sometimes a
touch of mustard,
which we're not
going to have today.
So I wanted to bring,
in one bite, the feeling
and the emotion of
eating a salad, which
is a touch of earthiness
from the lettuce.
Obviously, a touch of
acidity with the vinegar,
and a touch of the
sweetness, because I
feel that when
you eat something,
you need to have all the texture
of life, which is sweetness,
acidity, and earthiness.
There is more than that also.
There is love, and whatever.
Anyway, so this dish, you
can't make it in 31 minutes.
There is a lot of process.
It takes us up to
24 hours to make it.
So there is two ways we can do.
I can walk through.
Maybe I'll just walk
them through it.
All right.
So first, the idea was
to make a meringue.
And you're like, what?
A meringue?
This is not good.
So the meringue for us
was to create a vessel
to hold the salad.
So this is how we're
making the meringue.
It's made with a lot
of interesting things.
It's made with Banyuls vinegar,
sugar, a different type
of hydrocolloid.
The is also glucose and egg
white, an all those things.
So you bring them together.
The reason we use
some hydrocolloid
is to stabilize the meringue and
the xanthan gum and all that.
And we dehydrate the meringue
for up to five hours.
And so this meringue
is not really sweet.
It tastes like Banyuls.
So that is my base for the
vinegar, Banyuls vinegar.
So what we do with it, we
just make a little boat.
My cooks love me, because it
takes them about two hours
to make those meringues.
And if the base is not
right, then the meringue
will not dehydrate properly.
And then when you have
50 people at night,
and if it's not
ready, and if I don't
serve that for my customer,
then the chef gets very angry.
So it's very intense.
So this is the best.
It's a meringue Banyuls.
Then we make Banyuls gel.
You can do this at home.
It's pretty easy.
I mean, you can use
any type of vinegar.
You can use agar-agar.
Which is very simple.
Make sure you dried
the agar-agar.
And then you just
kind of broke the gel.
Agar-agar is found anywhere.
You can find it in any store.
I wanted to have, also,
life is about also feeling.
So this is a feeling of like,
you can eat also the vinegar.
I will make everybody
taste, individually, this.
And then we made,
also, an olive oil gel.
And this is made with
eggs, yolk, and olive oil.
We vacuum.
Basically, we mix the
egg yolk, we vacuum it.
And then we add a little bit
of water to stabilize it.
And then add the olive oil, and
then we make a gel out of it.
So this is really the component
of oil and vinegar vinaigrette.
Very easy.
And this is a vessel.
So the way we do
this in-- do you
guys want to taste
the gel first,
before I-- Just go a little
bit around, and then just put
a little bit on your finger.
Please make sure you
don't put too much so you
can share with everyone.
And then this is the olive
oil, so people can taste it.
So Banyuls vinegar
is a French vinegar.
You can get it, I
think, Whole Foods.
Whole Foods has it,
which is surprising,
but I think they do.
I think maybe
Rainbow also has it.
Maybe.
I don't know if you
can find it at-- I
don't shop at Safeway or those.
I don't, so I'm sorry.
I don't like big corporations,
and mall food is also bad.
I mean, this is a
big corporation.
This is not what I'm saying.
Did you guys taste the vinegar?
Where's the vinegar?
AUDIENCE: The vinegar is here.
DOMINIQUE CRENN: OK.
Just did you give that
to them over there?
Oh yeah.
Did you taste it?
No?
I think it's important.
I think if you want to cook
at home and a little bit more
out there, that's why
I also wrote the book.
You know, it's all
about that inspiration.
And then if you have
little techniques
to integrate in your dinner
with friends, I think it's fun.
You know, those meringues,
you can make those.
Obviously, I don't know if you
can find those hydrocolloids
at the store.
You're going to have
to order them online.
You can make regular meringue.
The reason why we use those
hydrocolloids, because we
use vinegar, which is acidic.
And you can make just regular
meringue, put them in the oven.
Or you can dehydrate
it overnight.
Just have a lot of
fun with it, and just
make whatever vinaigrette or
gel that you want, you know?
I think it's all about
bringing new, fun things to do.
So did you guys
taste everything?
Do you guys taste the olive oil?
Takes a long time.
Do you guys have
any other questions?
AUDIENCE: And is
it the poem first?
DOMINIQUE CRENN: OK.
So I started to write poetry
when I was four years old.
And that's how I expressed
myself about life.
And then I never
believed to write a menu,
because I think it's boring
to look at the ingredients.
I don't know.
So I started to write
poetry before doing--
it was a kind of a feeling of
what I felt for the season.
And then the dishes came after.
But now it's very 50-50.
I wrote a menu in
the spring of 2012
before to do anything else.
I was taking care of a little
girl that had leukemia.
And she passed away
right before spring time,
and the menu was the
point was all about her.
And all the dishes just
follow up after that.
So it used to be before,
and now it's just now.
I can write you a poem
right now if you want.
So yeah.
It's kind of like, a poem,
you can follow the dish.
I mean, usually every
dish is as a line,
but it's also we want people
to just come there, and just
have fun, and enjoy the food.
And the poem, you can
read it before or after.
But it's just a way of
interacting with you guys.
You've never been to Atelier?
AUDIENCE: Several times.
DOMINIQUE CRENN: Oh.
AUDIENCE: We go for
our anniversary.
DOMINIQUE CRENN: Oh.
My customer.
Right here.
What was the last
time you were there?
AUDIENCE: February
11th of this year.
DOMINIQUE CRENN: Oh.
So February 11.
OK.
Oh, menu's totally
different right now.
Where's my olive oil?
AUDIENCE: Over here.
DOMINIQUE CRENN:
Oh, you like it.
You want to keep it.
Did you guys try the Banyuls?
Yeah?
Is it good?
AUDIENCE: It's very good.
Yeah.
DOMINIQUE CRENN: Who tried it?
Who didn't try it?
The meringue?
Everybody?
Oh, you're sharing.
That's so nice of you.
All right.
So this is what we do.
So we take the meringue,
we make a little boat.
Like a little bit, a hole.
And then we just put
the Banyuls gel on top,
mix it with a little
bit of olive oil gel.
And then from the garden,
which is yours, then
we try to-- you had
the salad, right?
OK.
Many times, right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DOMINIQUE CRENN: How was it?
AUDIENCE: Fantastic.
DOMINIQUE CRENN: Fantastic.
I love that.
And then we just add
whatever is in season.
And I think what's important
for us, like I said,
we have a little
garden upstairs,
and outside also, where
we grew little greens,
microgreens, some flowers.
And when you make a salad,
what's interesting is,
you don't take just
one type of lettuce.
I think you need to mix it.
Some need to be bitter, some
need to be more crunchy.
And that's what's going
to make a beautiful salad.
So if you just want to eat a
romaine salad, I don't know.
Sorry.
Making a salad at Google.
OK, so I think that's it.
What do we have?
Oh, we have a little kale here.
And so this is how we serve it.
Usually it comes on a wood,
whatever vessel we have.
And then what we ask the
customer is to take this,
and to eat it at once,
one bite, and then I
think what you
experience is really
the feeling of the emotion of
eating a salad without just
in one bite.
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: Fresh.
AUDIENCE: It opens
up the menu, right?
DOMINIQUE CRENN: It's
right at the end.
Oh, you see she's been there.
No, at the beginning of
the menu, it's Kir Breton.
AUDIENCE: Oh, it's
the white chocolate.
DOMINIQUE CRENN: Yes.
To open up your--
explosion in your mouth.
OK guys.
AUDIENCE: How are the dishes
developed at Atelier Crenn?
Is it like a collaborative
effort with your various chefs,
or is it more driven by you?
DOMINIQUE CRENN: Well I think at
the beginning of Atelier Crenn,
it was definitely
more driven by me.
I think when you
create a team, there
is a lot of different
personalities, I would say.
And I think you need to
come together as a team.
And now it's really a
collaboration with my vision.
So some dishes can take
four months to develop.
For example, we had, I
will say, my pastry chef
is about probably four,
sometimes five months.
In pastry, what we
do, we take an idea.
And then we create
our own vessel.
So we had someone to-- I
need a tissue, because I
think my nose is running.
And I don't think it's sexy.
Thank you.
Sorry guys.
Kidding.
So we try to do-- I
mean, you see there
is a lot of different vessels.
So we asked people.
We like to involve other artists
to make the vessels or plates.
Like, for example,
we had-- I don't
know if you guys know anything
about bees in California,
and the political aspect of it.
And we need to save bees.
I think it's very important.
So we created a dessert to
bring awareness of that.
And it's called honey.
I don't know if you guys.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So I just remembered we were
there in February and in May.
And it was a dripping
honeycomb that was standing.
DOMINIQUE CRENN: And then
you got the honey cake.
And it was very
interesting, because we've
been working with some honey
keepers back in Sonoma.
And when we started to cook
the honey in the kitchen in San
Francisco, then suddenly there
was like bees coming into-- it
was crazy.
It was coming into the kitchen.
So dessert can take up
to four or five months.
We have a dessert right now.
I don't think you have it.
It's called the forest.
It's a celebration
of the forest.
And it's a reproduction of
walking in the forest, which
was a dish that we created
back in 2011 on the savory dish
side.
And now it's like sweet.
And we had to have someone
to make the vessel for it,
so it took about three months.
Some other dishes can take,
I don't know, two minutes.
No, I'm kidding.
That's a joke.
No everything is
very thoughtful.
You know, I think we
don't want to throw dishes
that don't mean anything.
So I think often when
we think about season,
is it's not just about the food.
It's about the idea,
and the feeling,
and the emotion around it.
You know, I think
we live in a world
right now that is, I think
the world is in trouble.
I'm sorry.
I'm going to be very
political right now.
And climate change and all that.
So everything that, I
think, the next menu
is going to be very focused
on bringing those awareness
through our own dishes.
So it takes a
little bit of time.
And I'm very
fortunate and I'm very
lucky to have this
incredible team that
has been working with me.
I mean, we are a very small
team, and they work long hours.
But I just love
the way they think.
And it's very inspiring for me.
AUDIENCE: I don't want
to hog the mic too much.
One of my favorite
dishes, the vessel
was a glass box with the leaves
inside of it with the bark.
It was probably two
or three years ago.
And it had the bubbler with
the tea, with the squash.
DOMINIQUE CRENN: Oh, yes.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: And it was
like to represent fall.
DOMINIQUE CRENN: Yeah, it was.
It was summertime.
Not kidding.
AUDIENCE: I like this quiz.
How do you even determine
the thought into the art?
So it's like the bubbler.
That is the tea, right?
And then the tree that
came out of the glass box.
Like all of that was
so thoughtful, right?
So like that was a
vessel that I loved.
I guess, maybe it's
your magic, right?
Like transforming the
thought and the food
into the presentation.
DOMINIQUE CRENN: I don't
know if it's magic.
But I think it's
about being conscious
about your surroundings.
And I thing, for us,
when you do something,
you have to celebrate where
those things come from.
For me, nature is number one.
Nature and art, and
food is another thing.
But like everything.
So if you do a dish, is where
those ingredients come from,
and what is the surrounding,
and what it means.
We have also eucalyptus.
Eucalyptus is a
plant, obviously,
that comes from Australia, and
then was given to San Francisco
a long time ago.
And there's eucalyptus
tree all over.
So it's also to celebrate
out surroundings.
So we need to integrate those
to be a part of the story.
Otherwise, I don't know.
Otherwise, I'm just
another chef cooking food.
It's kind of boring, I think.
But whatever.
But, yeah there is
a lot of thought.
And once again, it is
being lucky to work with,
like my pastry chef, we been
working together since 2006.
And it's been a journey.
And it's continuing to make
sure that everything we do
is conscious and thoughtful.
So being thoughtful is very
much the core of who we are.
AUDIENCE: I know you have been
such an advocate for farmers,
which is so amazing.
Could you talk a little
bit about, maybe,
one or two of your
relationships that you have,
and kind of how that works?
Like if it's a back
and forth relationship.
It sounded like
with the honey one
in Sonoma, like maybe
you offer ideas, perhaps,
about what it is you
want and they provide it.
Or is it a dialogue?
DOMINIQUE CRENN:
It is a dialogue.
So some background.
So both of my parents
come from farmers.
So I grew up kind of in that.
And they're just amazing people.
And I always say, farmers are
the rock stars, not the chef.
It's very important to say
that, because it's true.
No, I think with the farmers,
we do have a dialogue with them,
but I feel that they know
things better than I know.
So I always tell them to
give us whatever they have
for us to be able to create.
I don't want to tell
them what to do.
They don't tell me
what to do, so I don't
want to tell them what to do.
And there's a lot of chefs
that will go to a farmer
and say, well you've
got to do this and this.
I think when you understand
the makeup of a farm,
there are things that you
might not be able to grow.
And if you have pressure
to grow those things,
I don't think that works.
So we have a farm in Sonoma.
Then I work with a lot
of different farmers
most of the special
things that to grow
and I just let them
do whatever they want.
And I really love them.
I think they are amazing.
They're really cool people.
Very humble too.
We need them.
So make sure next time
when you buy food,
make sure you buy from a farmer.
AUDIENCE: So I had
a similar question
about when you decide where
to source things from.
Like are you looking at
ethical farming practices?
Like what thought goes
into your decision
when you decide to source
an ingredient from somebody?
DOMINIQUE CRENN: Yes.
I think I said before,
not just for me,
but I said before
that we all need
to be advocates with
the way that we do.
And then I think when you go
eat somewhere, it's an action.
So I like to know where
my food comes from.
I like to know the
practice of it.
I understand some people will
argue that organic food is
very expensive.
But it's also, you
have farmers that
do sustainable practice without
having organic practices.
So yeah.
Everything that we do and
everything that we have,
actually, is.
I mean, even the employee
meal is like all organic
and is from farmers, and local.
And as far as my
cheese, I don't know.
I like French cheese, so I
buy my cheese from France.
But no.
Even any producer,
we talk to them.
We know all the stories.
We know everything behind it.
And I think this
is very important.
And that's, I think, that's
what the future's going to be.
The future is not going to
be about industrial farming.
The future is going to
be about small farming,
but we need to support them.
I think it's very important.
And I know it's very expensive
to go to the farmer's market.
The Ferry building--
I don't know.
I live in San Francisco.
But I don't know.
I think we need to find
a system to make sure
that if we want to
support them, they
need to be in sync with us.
Maybe the price needs--
maybe the government
needs to be involved,
which is another story.
AUDIENCE: My question
for you is, is there
an ingredient that
when you see, you're
just like, this is my favorite
ingredient to cook with.
Or you love it, because
it's a challenge.
Or it just makes your
day, and vice versa.
Is there an
ingredient that you're
just like, this ingredient, I
just don't like working with.
DOMINIQUE CRENN: Red pepper.
Yeah, like green pepper.
I dislike those ingredients.
I just don't.
No, I think every
ingredient is beautiful.
I like ingredients
that are not luxurious.
I like ingredients that
are just on the dog.
But, no.
I don't like red paper,
or yellow, or green.
It has puzzled me when I see,
when I ask chefs sometime when
they put that on the plate.
And it's like, well
this is for color.
I just, I don't like that.
So that's the
ingredient I don't like.
It doesn't mean that I'm right.
But my favorite
ingredient is tomato.
So tomato, yes.
I love tomato.
Tomato could be a
vegetable, could be a fruit.
So I love tomato.
It has a lot of umami,
and it's just delicious,
the texture of it.
AUDIENCE: So we talked
about ingredients.
That's kind of micro level.
And on macro level, you
combine different dishes
in a certain way.
It sounds groundbreaking,
because you
start with white chocolate,
then a main dish, than a salad.
And can you talk
a little bit more
about how you
combine different--?
DOMINIQUE CRENN:
Well I think people
need to think outside
of the box sometimes.
I think we are in a society
when there is one way and not
the other way.
And it's like if you just
had a baby, you go to a store
then this is girl clothing
and boys' clothing.
I think everything
needs to be unisex.
Anyway, that's how
I think about food.
It's not just
chocolate needs to be
in dessert, because
when you think
about cocoa, what is cocoa?
What is cocoa nibs?
It's pretty bitter.
So I like to mix
sweetness and bitterness.
And I think that's interesting.
It's the same thing when
we pair our food with wine.
You know, it's
not like you can't
have red wine with seafood.
I say, yes you can.
For us, it's just
finding the balance.
We also understand the molecular
profile of every ingredient,
which is quite interesting.
You can mix cauliflower
with bleu cheese.
It's delicious.
Cauliflower and chocolate
is delicious also,
because they have a very
similar molecular profile.
So they go very well together.
So it's also understanding.
And some people will
nod, because it's
all about education.
And some things don't
work, but that's OK.
But yeah.
I mean, the first dish, it's a
frozen explosion of apple cider
that is served with a reduction
of creme de cassis and cocoa
butter.
I don't think it's
sweet, but it's just--
AUDIENCE: My question is
around inspiration, and where
you kind of look for
a way to recharge,
and renew your thinking.
Because I think, whenever I look
around other areas of creation,
I think there's always
ways and methods people
kind of go back to the well.
And kind of draw back and see
new things and new experiences
that help create new stuff.
So my question for you is,
what are those areas for you,
where you kind of
go back to the well
and see and recharge, renew.
Whether it be like a
new season or a new menu
that needs to come up?
And I guess along those
lines, are there other chefs
or other folks in
the food arena that
are doing interesting
things right
now that you think are cool?
DOMINIQUE CRENN: Well I
mean, my personal inspiration
is not about going to
a restaurant of food.
I love museums.
I love interesting movies.
I love to talk to people.
I love to be aware about
the different cultures.
I love to travel.
I'm still a baby.
I'm still learning.
So I think it's when
I go into the world,
I've always got an open
mind, and see things
that can draw my attention.
And kind of spark
something inside of me.
But it's interesting, because
I think I always go back
to a piece of my memory that has
been triggered a long time ago.
But I think it's very important
for me to be in the world
and be inspired by
different artists.
And even politics inspire me.
I mean, making the honey
dessert was very political.
And as I say, I mean, we don't
look into anything perfect.
So when we do something,
it's not about perfection.
It's really about evolution.
So how do you achieve evolution?
It's always to be in the
world and always learn.
I'm sure that you
guys do that here too.
It's about evolution.
Google.
Google was a few years ago.
20 years ago?
How long ago did it exist?
20 years?
Ten years?
15 years?
OK, so what Google
was 15 years ago
is not what Google is today.
And it's all about evolution.
So this is why we think the
way we think in the kitchen.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
any favorite restaurants?
DOMINIQUE CRENN: Where?
AUDIENCE: Either locally
or abroad, I guess.
DOMINIQUE CRENN: So my favorite
restaurant in the United States
is Blue Eel Stone Farm.
If you don't know
anything about Ben Barber,
I will recommend to just
read a little bit about him
and his way of cooking.
It's amazing.
San Francisco.
There's a lot of great
restaurants in San Francisco.
Where do I hang out?
Anywhere.
Zuni Cafe.
I was a local in
there last night.
But in the world, one of
my favorite restaurants
is Michel Bras in
Laguiole in France.
I love Quique Dacosta
in Denia, Valencia.
Andoni is the chef of
Mugaritz in San Sebastian.
This is places that
I like, but I'm
fond to-- there's a lot of
restaurants that I love.
I think I admire chefs and cooks
that go out there, and speak,
and dialogue with us
with their own food.
And being personal.
So I'm just very open.
And then my restaurant
is very good too.
You know, I've got to
tell you, every day when
I work at Atelier, when
I'm done with Atelier,
I go to Petit Crenn,
and I sit at the bar.
And this is mine.
It's a lot, you know.
And I get a glass of wine,
or rose, and some oysters.
And I feel at home, and
I think that's important.
But there's a lot of
great restaurants.
I mean, it's pretty humbling
to be in a city that
has so many talented people.
And I feel lucky
to be a part of it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I think I
speak for everyone when I say,
what an inspiration you are.
And what a treat it's been to
spend a little time with you
here this afternoon.
So thank you.
And we'll give you
a round of applause.
DOMINIQUE CRENN: I don't
think you've ever done--
[APPLAUSE]